very big news that I want to couch in some
factual realities.
Joe Biden yesterday signed an executive order
directing the Justice Department to end its
use of private prisons.
Joe Biden yesterday telling the Justice Department
and the reliance on private prisons acknowledge
the central role that the federal government
has played in implementing discriminatory
housing policies.
And Joe Biden made some remarks before signing
these orders saying that the US government
needs a completely new approach to the issue
of racial equity.
He said the country is less prosperous and
less secure because of systemic racism, saying
we must change now.
It will take time, but we can do it.
And Biden called on the Justice Department
to curb the use of private prisons right away.
Now, I think that this is very important.
We've talked before about private prisons
versus public prisons, but there are a couple
caveats here.
And I want to be really clear.
I'm not raining on Joe Biden's parade, but
what I want people to understand is the reality
of the numbers.
First of all, in the United States, most inmates
are held in state facilities, not federal
facilities.
So in general, when we're talking about federal
prisons, it's a slice, a relatively small
one of all inmates.
Generally speaking, if you look only at private
prisons, most private prison inmates are in
state private prisons.
And in fact, just a few years ago, if you
look at all inmates in private prisons, 78
percent of them are in state private prisons.
Only 22 percent of private prison inmates
are in federal private prisons.
So the vast majority of inmates and the vast
majority of private prison inmates are state
inmates who would not be in any way directly
affected by what Joe Biden is saying.
Now, that being said, it is still very important
that Joe Biden is doing this.
Number one, the Bureau of Prisons, Federal
Bureau of Prisons recently opted not to renew
some private prison contracts in the recent
months as the number of inmates has been dwindling
and many were released to home confinement
because of the coronavirus pandemic.
This is the perfect time to say let's keep
going in that direction.
And furthermore, there's no doubt that there
are many states that will take the lead from
the federal government.
When the federal government says at the federal
level for federal inmates, we are going to
get away from private prisons.
Certainly at least the more blue states and
maybe purple states would see that as a signal
as the door opening for them to do the exact
same thing.
So I do think that this is extraordinarily
important going forward.
There's going to be there's another issue
that follows this, which is that there are
many private prisons that have occupancy minimums
where essentially they have a contract with
the state or federal government.
It's mostly state, but they're state and federal
where they say, OK, we will run this prison
for you, but you need to guarantee us a certain
occupancy rate.
If you drop below that occupancy rate, you
still have to pay us as if we were that full.
And what that generates is a perverse incentive
to lower the bar at which you lock people
up.
If we have a 92 percent occupancy requirement
with this prison, but really we're only using
85 percent, there's money we're paying as
if we were locking people up, even though
there's nobody locked up.
Let's find some people to lock up so we get
our so-called money's worth from these contracts.
It's completely perverse.
It's it could not be a more backward system.
So if we are, this is a great first step.
We're on day seven.
Yesterday was day six for Joe Biden or I guess
the start of day seven yesterday for Joe Biden.
This is a great start.
There's no question about it.
But if we really want.
To permanently reduce incarceration, it's
not just about doing away with the contracts
with private prisons, we also need to change
the approach as to who do we even try to put?
Who do prosecutors even ask for prison time
for?
That's obviously a much bigger issue and it's
one that we've talked about before and we'll
continue to talk about.
But I agree completely with Joe Biden in doing
this.
Let's hope some states follow suit and let's
hope we actually deal with, you know, there
is a trickle down effect here, which is what
kind of policing do we do?
Who gets arrested for what crimes, who gets
charged, what penalties and sentences are
requested.
All of that stuff runs downhill, so to speak,
and ends up with what number of people do
we have in prisons and what level of demand
do we have for bunks or cells, I guess is
what we would call them.
And you've got to start at the top and allow
those changes to trickle down.
Joe Biden here sort of starting towards the
bottom, but that's OK.
And hopefully he will do much more.
We'll have more about this on our Instagram
page.
Find us on Instagram at The David Pakman Show,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.